I wrote a song like a sucker friend of
mine you know he has a lot of dating
profiles and he was like will you make
you a video with me funny
it's getting pretty competitive so we
make the video was funny but everything
he said about every fact I was like you
don't make that much money
that's not your jet like what the [__]
who's going up and he goes everybody
lies I said really he goes everybody
lives and he said if you go to profile
with you and he said would you make a
video so good night everybody
[Music]
you know that I need you baby you know
that I got you baby
[Music]
I [__] with my socks out I [__] with my
black socks on and girl good circulation
baby my feet are like ice cubes baby
deep vein thrombosis baby I'm on
medication couple of the things I should
probably tell you my legs are pale
they're almost kind of light blue
there's chance that I'll touch up in you
and my stamina is not what it used to be
so when we think you gotta get on top
but I'll have my side
have my black socks on my girls and I
also I also shave my shoulder
[Applause]